Look,
I'm like spooky today.
I'm spooky every day.
Oh my god.
What?
It's 5 a.m.
Oh, we just started.
Oh, it's 5 a.m.
in Japan.
It's 5 a.m.
Wow,
it's 5 a.m.
in Japan.
For everybody.
Waking up in Japan.
Today, I'm playing Stingbotized Property Hello, Minto and
I've always like you My advice for the day Get a ticket To
from Minto with love General or streaming Or whatever you
get Go, go, go Go, Minto's looking less minty today
Impossible Impossible
Yes, for those who have heard about my live 3D jazz show the
first time, the first show sold out.
So we added a second show, a second late night show even.
So I'm going to be so jet lagged and silly.
I'm like, oh gosh, will I even be able to sing?
Oh no.
So a second show has been announced.
Tickets will be announced via Oshi Spark.
So, yes.
And then, of course, it will also be streamed.
So there will be streaming tickets as well.
But yeah.
Yeah.
I was like, I was like, if there's any way we could do a
second show, I want to.
I'm already going gray at 19.
Did you, you see my hair, it's all white.
I've, I'm, I'm way beyond.
I'm beyond monochrome minto.
Yeah.
Any idea of streaming tickets will be just the first show.
Actually, let me see if I can ask.
Um.
Uh, hold on.
Oh, gosh, they're asking me about things.
Um, I...
Wait.
Sorry.
Oh, not...
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I didn't see this before I started.
Hold on.
Hold.
I'm sorry.
Oh, do we work?
Uh...
The ASMR here, I'll move my mic over so that you can hear me
typing.
Uh...
Sorry.
So, one second.
Okay.
Tapa, tapa.
Tapa, tapa, tapa.
Oh.
Oh!
Streaming tickets will be for the first show only.
Sorry.
It says on the website.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
So much has happened with this...
with this... with this...
uh peppermint club show it has been it has been a bit
challenging but we persevere so um hopefully it will still
be a really great show oh no not hopefully i know it will be
still a very great show for you guys if you um if you come
or if you watch on the stream so thank you thank you guys
Wenchua wasn't enough for someone like Yuhaminto If he
wanted us so badly On Valentine's he could have just asked
I'm starting to think you might like us Or something
Yeah I'm making sure that you can't spend Valentine's with
anybody else at midnight Spaghetti Spaghetti I hope I can
get streaming tickets Thank you Boom, boom, boom.
But yeah.
Spaghetti.
I booze are each other's valentines.
Exactly.
Very excited that we were able to announce that.
But today, right now, playing Japan Stigmatized property
which is spooky have you guys heard of these before i've
probably because there have been other games based off of
stigmatized properties like the chela's art game right but
for those who don't know basically a stigmatized property is
like a place where somebody has passed um or like a violent
crime has occurred and so um oh i don't mean like the game i
mean like the act like the actual stigmatized properties in
japan no i'm not talking about the game i'm talking about
what stigmatized properties are you guys not like the game
not the get like if you've heard of if you've heard of the
actual term before yeah it's based on irl stuff it's the bad
juju exactly exactly it's places that got that funky energy
maybe are you scouting for new mid cafe I don't want to be
in a place that's haunted by somebody else.
That's too crowded.
No roommates.
Ghost hunting.
Found one.
There's a house near me that's a stigmatized property.
Freaky.
Nah.
Actually, in my last maid's cafe, there was a place by me
that was a stigmatized property.
I remember I remember I was coming back from haunting and
and uh there were a bunch of police and everything and I was
like whoa what's going on and I I did a little snooping and
it turns out that like the sun had gone crazy and like
killed this whole family But, yeah, freaky.
Mint wants a place to herself.
That's why she's clearing out one of these from the spooks.
The ghosts here.
I don't know.
I don't think we're...
I don't know if we're getting rid of them or not.
They might be here to stay.
We might just be identifying them.
Is your cafe a stigmatized property?
I don't know.
Mysterious.
If someone died here Who would die in a maid cafe?
That's like ridiculousness Do ghosts cost extra?
No, actually these properties End up being cheaper It's kind
of awesome Get the proton packs No!
Me No!
I activity spikes when monitoring snake i keep thinking that
sound effect is my doorbell that sound it's kind of creepy
that's a doorbell bell sound the ghost should have to pay
rent though i disagree you can't force me to pay rent but
yeah so the guy who lived in my place before me died in
there there's still damage on the door from where they had
to break it down thankfully i'm only haunted by minto they
had to break it down that's scary wow that's creepy dexy oh
my gosh there was one time i was at like an idol show and my
oshi she was just so casually talking about how like her mom
sees a bunch of ghosts and stuff and like just how her place
is haunted and i was like i knew you were my Ži for a reason
i knew it i knew you were my Ži for a reason just like just
her cat she was just like yeah and like as a kid i would see
this and that And sometimes I still sometimes see things.
And I'm like, well, you know, she definitely, she definitely
sees things.
Because she sees me.
But I don't think she knows I'm a ghost.
She probably thinks I'm like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Are you haunting her?
Just a little bit.
Stop flirting with your Oshi's mother's bit.
No, it's not me.
I would never, I would never, I would never.
I don't wanna be her, I don't wanna, I don't, I'm like,
okay, usually, this has happened a couple times where I
become friends with my Oshis, but usually I very much like,
don't talk to me.
I don't, I'm too, you are, you are, you are, you are heaven,
and I am just a lowly being.
I am just a spirit creature.
Do not, do not perceive me.
I just want to, I just want to be like, admiring you from
afar.
To my bushi.
Yes, yes, yes.
Hi, Minky.
Hello.
What's up, Reese?
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
You can't disappoint a picture.
Usually though, I know the people say don't meet your
heroes, but like for me, every time I've met my hero, it's
been pretty great.
So, I don't know.
I have no idea why I'm asking this now.
But if the NFL invited Den Setsu EXE to do the halftime show
at the Super Bowl, would you do it?
We're gonna take the Super Bowl!
MVP!
Maybe.
The superb owl.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Baby.
I don't know anything about football.
I guess you don't have to know anything to...
To do the halftime show.
But...
Um...
What was it?
I could ask Steiner about, um...
Doing an...
Uh...
Running an ad.
during the Super Bowl.
It should only cost a little bit.
Everybody please join the Patreon and then send to EXA
Patreon so that we can have an ad.
We can have an ad during the Super Bowl.
Okay, surely.
Surely we can...
Can I get a birthday?
A birthday.
What, what?
From me, doll.
The rather happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday!
Just a few million for 30 seconds.
What if we had just one second?
What if it was just like, ah!
And that was it.
Just like a ah!
One second, I think is what, a million, no?
Seven to eight million for 30 seconds.
Oh, wait, no, we could totally do that then.
They probably don't have a minimum.
Everybody join the...
Join Dead Setsu Yixi.
Patreon.
You'll get a...
You'll get a monthly checky.
Monthly artwork.
It's 100k for a subliminal ad.
Yeah.
Everyone will be like, Nobody's going to talk about the ad
that appeared for one second.
We could be like, about to be like, Super Bowl.
And it could just be like, soup.
It go viral for sure.
I think so.
And yet they are talking about it.
Soup.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I'm going to tag Steiner right now.
Wait, hold on.
Can you...
Ah, Steiner.
Can you look into how much a...
He said not!
He already messaged me!
I'm at a soup!
Oh my gosh, wait, Steiner!
It's so good!
I didn't even get to finish my message!
Then he just sent a soup emoji.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
Make the Super Bowl add one second, but then have a freeze
frame paragraph of everything that Setsui exists about
making people read the whole thing.
He said, we'll think about it.
Yippee!
I wonder if they have a minimum, though.
There's like minimum five second add.
Surely not.
They definitely do.
No, surely not.
Otherwise, can you imagine?
Otherwise, people, like, so many people would be buying
one-second ads.
So many people.
Oh, my God.
He just sent me, please wrap it up.
This is really rude.
God, I think that I'm really on to something.
He doesn't like my yapping.
Maybe they never tried because they're too scared.
I think if you don't ask, you'll never know.
Oh my god.
Get in the hook.
This is so rude.
I'm closing Discord right now.
I'm not listening to you anymore.
I'm gonna fire you, Steiner.
I'm making an executive decision.
Okay.
Densetsu EXA merch idea Densetsu soup Yummy Yummy Is this
revenge for them?
Wait, hold on though Let me, wait Hold on The, it's the The
This is what I sent the to It wasn't the were Soros talk It
was called the we warisaurus Hold on, let me We
there we go the we warisaurus hot dog there should be one ad
break that is just like 131 130 oh 131 second ads I need to
know about this dinosaur it's so cute sounding no the we
warisaurus we warisaurus and I sent it to Phoebe because I
was like, this is so Phoebe core.
Like, I was like, Phoebe, it's called the Weewarosaurus
pobeni.
So it's almost even close to Phoebe.
Weewarosaurus.
It's such a cute name.
Is this Mint Talk episode?
The Weewarosaurus pobeni.
Cobeni?
Wait, what was cobeni from?
Oh, wait, what was, what was cobeni from again?
Put that out of me.
Oh, chainsaw man.
No, I'm thinking of somebody else.
I'm thinking of something from like a slice of life.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm thinking of somebody from like a slice of life.
Oh, I was thinking of engaged the unidentified.
Her name is Colbeni.
I was listening to that song just the other day, like the
opening.
So I was thinking about it yeah yeah yeah cool venue I
really liked that show and the opening is so cute you guys
know the game um miracle girl miracle girl stage miracle go
project miracle girl something it was for the PSP reader why
can't I remember first of all miracle girls festival it was
a miracle girls festival and And it was a bunch of shows
from...
It was a bunch of shows.
A bunch of anime.
But it was basically...
It was like Project Diva.
But if it was like anime girls instead of like, you know,
just Hatsune Miku.
We wear a Wariosaurus for Nintendo Wii.
Oh no!
Boy, that'd be awesome.
And so it's like Project...
Project Diva, but if it was anime girls.
And so you had like wake up girls and you had Ungeashida
unidentified and you had Gochi Usa and you had Nyaruko and
and all these other things.
And it was just a rhythm game but you got to watch them.
They had like they had like dances and everything and it was
really cute.
It was really, really cute.
And you could change their outfits and stuff.
Oh, Miracle Girls Festival.
that but Hatsune Miku is anime girl like actually does have
her own anime oh wait no you can't say that like what was
that the movie that came out you can't call it Hatsune Miku
anime because all the all the um project Sakai people get
angry at you um they they because they'll be like um
actually it's a project Sakai game uh it is not a Miku anime
and you need to be correct I'm like, oh no.
Typical Pro-Sekai fans.
But Miku is in it.
Yeah, but you can't call it a Miku movie or else it's like
false advertising.
I guess they like have, they very much care.
They have, they, the other Pro-Sekai like characters in the
Moba Gate are very cherished.
And so they're just like, you are erasing them.
telling me about the we war source i didn't know about it of
course i love sometimes i just like sometimes i just look up
like dinosaurs but i will like to find places like dinosaurs
that are like from places if that makes sense like this
fossil was found only here in this country or something You
know, things like that.
Wow, haven't heard of Miracle Girl in a long time, so you
played Miracle Girls Festival.
Let me bury your child.
Stop me from burying your child, right, Minto?
Huh?
Yes.
What do you think of my country's exclusive dynamic?
to sort of the chile sorus.
Sounds delicious.
I understood that reference.
I understand.
What are you, what if I don't understand?
Oh no!
Chile sorus.
Mmm.
Chili.
My bed shakes randomly for no reason and feels like someone
is crawling in it when I'm trying to sleep.
Are you the one?
I'm not hunting you.
I might haunt you.
But I'm not shaking any beds.
I think you got someone else Jurassic Park Watch Along when?
Should we?
We could see my favorite Terrasaur, Ketzelco Atlas.
I would be really excited about that.
Only the first four.
But he isn't the most recent one!
Anyway, should we play the game now?
Tofu, NSGT, thank you, welcome back.
Minky the stalker now spooking.
No, this game is an observation type game, you guys.
So if you'd like to join along and just scream whenever you
see something, you could just be like, ah, in the chat.
That would be really, really great.
Yeah, we can still yapp while checking out the cameras.
Oh, in this game, the properties that appear are real ones.
The spiritual disturbances and incidents that have actually
been reported.
Numerous cases of participants disappearing, getting into
traffic accidents, and suffering harm at home have been
reported in the original business.
Our company takes no responsibility for any troubles that
may occur during or after gameplay.
Scary.
Oh my gosh, there was one exhibit that I really wanted to go
to in Japan.
but unfortunately I wasn't there before it ended.
But it was like an exhibition where on one side you go
through if you can see spirits and then there's another side
that you go through if you can't.
And so it was like a bunch of ghost photography from like
places like this.
And if you went through the side where you couldn't see the
ghosts, they would like kind of mark out what you see.
And then if you go through the side where you can see
spirits, you just have like all the pictures hanging up.
It's like, it's like a cool atmosphere.
To all employees.
Conduct business honestly, honestly, and seriously.
Oh, where's me?
This month's blank employees.
Oh my god, wait, that's so creepy.
Oh my god, it says like that...
Okay, so the people that died, and it says things like
accident, accident, something else, something else.
Please follow the content that follows closely.
Three, two, one.
Lock the doors and windows.
Okay.
Tell me, Roger.
Welcome to membership.
Cover the mirror with a cloth.
Okay.
Hide knives, strings, and drugs out of reach.
Do not close your eyes for more than three seconds.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm getting on my blinking out of the way.
If you sense something, don't look back.
Not the drugs.
Don't turn around even if you hear voices or hear a noise.
If blank contacts you, recite the following sentence.
Oh!
The game has jokes.
Get to work.
I wonder if there's loud noises in this.
I don't want to like jump scare you guys more than me.
What is special?
Oh, special pay is probably like, uh, I imagine probably,
um,
We're doomed?
No, no, no, we're not doomed.
Unreleased property.
We could go to Shizuoka, Kurodake, driving.
Tohori!
I had a friend that lived in Tohori, K residence.
Nagano.
Hotel Selene!
Where do you guys want to go?
Wait, what does it say?
Abandoned lodging facility, portraits and writings of a
pregnant woman remain.
That's quite specific.
Home where a solitary death occurred, an unidentifiable
altar remains.
Former rest stop with a ropeway, unidentified group activity
reported nearby.
What does that mean, a group activity?
Go in order?
Yeah, I guess we'll go in order, right?
Oh, here we go.
Business notification method, all right?
Watch the security camera monitor to check for any
abnormalities.
If you find any abnormality, press the area of mute.
to report it.
Example of work failures is overlooking four abnormalities,
incorrectly reporting a non-abnormal area five times in a
row.
Three times for special allowance work.
Please note that these are work failures.
Okay, we're five nights at Freddy's.
We're from 12 a.m.
to 5 a.m.
Examples of special anomaly report so far.
If an anomaly occurs that covers the entire field of view in
the camera, you can report it by selecting any part of the
field of view.
There will be some anomalies that will immediately fail if
left unattended for a long period of time if they occur.
I'm scared.
Don't be scared.
I'm a ghost right here.
There are some anomalies that cannot be seen unless you
switch between night vision and normal.
Oh, there's a night vision.
This explanation can also be reconfirmed on the monitor
during work.
So we switch and W is for the night vision and press and
hold to report the anomaly.
Is the tech spacing an anomaly?
I can't tell if it's on purpose or not.
Are you guys ready to observe?
Spooky happenings?
Right.
To all employees.
Paranormal activity was previously reported at your assigned
property.
Monitor the camera footage with the utmost caution.
If you notice any changes, report them immediately.
So that's our that's our night vision cam Okay, what is it?
This is a rest stop?
Oh, okay.
All right.
The night vision is so much easier to see, though.
I hear something in here.
Sounds like a bird.
You guys hear it?
seeing this thing and i'm like it's a red circle like around
like do you see it you know one of those kinds what the hell
are these their chairs what a kind of restop is this what is
this oh my gosh there's so many cameras okay
Did you see it?
Oh, I hear something in here.
Look at the graffiti.
Look at that guy.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
There's so many.
This is going to be tough, I think.
Oh, to all employees.
Yes?
This...
Wait, I just heard a knock.
Wait, there's...
report a phenomena.
If you notice any changes, please let us know.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, this...
Was there blood here before?
Uh-oh.
I already messed up.
What?
What did they spill?
That's no good.
Oh.
There's so much.
Anomaly, bottom right?
I'm trying not to cover up too much.
I don't think I am.
I don't like the hallway.
Typical mail washroom.
One time I went, it was during school.
Went on a field trip.
What's that sound?
And I remember this so vivid.
because we're tall employees.
Oh my gosh.
Multinomalies are currently detected.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Identify them without delay and report promptly.
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're gonna lose.
We're gonna...
Oh, there's a face!
Um, but I remember on the field trip, there was, um...
E!
have we had this joke poopy in the bloody toilet because
there was just so much poop in this toilet anyway sorry i
became more of a winded story than i expected
i see anything wait a second oh i thought that was a face
coming out of there like a stretched horse face you cool
yeah you're welcome I just thought I'd share that I just
thought it was really dramatic and that's why I still
remember it to this day it was like really bad girls toilets
wait was this door always open nope oh shoot okay it's open
the door is open everybody um oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
We're fine.
I'm reporting her?
Great bit, Mint.
Thanks.
Oh, it's daytime.
That doesn't seem right.
Meow.
What kind of ghost do I have to be to be able to control the
sky?
You know what I mean?
In such a way.
But I can control the time of day and everything.
I think I need to get stronger.
What was that?
You guys heard that, right?
It was like running or something.
I keep hearing weird noises in the bathroom!
God, I need to be God.
Is that something up there?
I don't know.
Pitter powder.
Oh, whoop, whoop.
My bad.
That was mean.
I will POV whenever Ben gets close to the screen.
Oh, there's a hand!
It's severed even.
Oh, nice.
Oh, report complete.
Okay, good, good, good.
That's that.
We were getting yelled at again.
Oh, that's not good.
Let's see some nooses.
Lots of going on in here.
That's not a very good room, I think.
Yes.
Yeah, this seems like a basement or something.
I can read.
Second floor basement.
Oh.
It seems like the place that is literally written in the
corner of the screen.
Vita for Reads.
I'm like gaming.
I'm not thinking about reading.
There has to be something in here.
Who would be running in the bathroom?
There's no space in here.
Also, these urinals seem very high up.
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Freaky!
Looked it up.
You'd be lazily named time ghost.
Ooh, time ghost.
Okay, grandpa.
Shut up.
The sound was so goofy.
I guess what's easier about this, I'm assuming, than other
anomaly games is that a lot of anomaly games will like mess
with the writing or stuff like that.
um like this would change like really dramatically you know
or like or like subtle sometimes very subtly too and um and
uh so it's this seems easier maybe was that a purple face
wait oh oh multiple anomalies are currently detected at your
property okay i'm working on it
Wait.
Oh, that's scary.
You can control our hearts.
Oh my god.
That's scary.
That was freaky.
Ew, I just got rid of one.
The other one came like that.
Oh, that was freaky.
Oh.
Did you see that?
Oh, hello.
Oh,
yeah.
These ones are like spooky faces, so it seems a little more
like, you know, just find the spooky person than find every
tiny little detail that you could ever see ever.
Memorize literally every section.
We haven't had anything in here either.
No huge man.
Maybe it sucks.
Oh, I thought this was like a shadow of a...
older or something.
Also, this Kiken.
Dangerous.
Ooh, freaky.
My literate Oshi.
That's me.
You guys see anything?
No, again?
Oh my god.
Please.
Where?
Where are the ghosts?
Bottom right?
Where?
Where are you?
Blood on the floor.
Where?
This?
Is this blood?
I'm gonna report it.
No anomaly.
Okay.
But the false reporting seems to reset after you, uh...
After you, um, get a correct thing, so...
In the outside view.
Oh, okay.
I'll go back.
Again!
Oh!
How is this paranormal?
That's just a spider making his home.
I still...
Oh!
There is blood here.
Oh, good catch, guys.
Why is there an ambulance coming?
Wee-woo, wee-woo.
Good catch.
Good catch, good catch.
I didn't see that blood at all.
Door open in the basement?
Is it not supposed to be usually?
Hmm.
E!
Oh!
Whoa!
That was kind of sick.
Oh!
There's a face up there, you see him?
He's like chatting.
Aren't you guys glad that I look so cute and I don't look
like this at all?
I'm not so spooky all the time.
It's still pretty scary, but you know.
That was Chet.
What is it?
This door?
This door was not open before?
This one?
No anomaly detected.
That's okay.
It usually gives us the warning when there's four, I think
it was.
Biblically accurate mint.
That's okay, we can still check.
As long as we don't get five wrong in a row, then I think
we're usually good.
Okay.
10 minutes ago you said Phenomenon perfectly.
I could
say Phenomenon.
I can't not say for Mamma Man's name.
I can't say it.
Wait, was that a sound anomaly?
I get it, I get it.
Oh, there's a man up here!
Finally, something in here.
E!
No worry, I got you.
Oh, the things that appear in the night vision, so scary.
I don't think I see it.
I keep looking at this guy, right?
I can't stop looking at him.
And this looks like hair to me.
You know what?
I'm gonna try reporting it, seeing if it's anything.
No, okay, no.
Oh!
You shouldn't be here.
Go away?
A real person is an anomaly?
Get the heck out of here?
You're trespassing?
I'm calling the cops.
There's like all this darkness here.
I'm going to report it too, but I don't think it's anything.
Okay.
That's all right.
Wait.
Okay.
Yeah.
Minto phenomenon.
What are you trying to make me shy?
Wee!
Oh.
We're okay.
Maybe.
Please don't kill me.
In the game.
I'm one of you.
Literally what are you?
I don't see anything.
I'd rather not!
Thank you so much for the phone.
Oh, Ted!
The Ted gift a thank you!
Oh my goodness, thank you so much.
For...
for... for mama made.
Phenomen made.
Oh my gosh, it's too difficult to say.
What's that sound?
I don't like it, somebody stepped up to my camera.
Wait, big toilet.
See, I told you they were too small.
I'm looking for faces.
I feel like faces are the easiest thing.
Big skip.
Oh my gosh, it kind of sounds like Kayako.
Well, they took it from dispatch.
I mean, wouldn't you prefer like a lot of space.
A lot of room to aim.
Almost time.
We just got 10 minutes left.
Oh.
Oh, that's blood.
There's a bunch of blood down there.
Like I actually caught that one this time.
No matter how big the urinal is, someone will miss.
Now ain't that just really sad.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
I missed one.
Object replacement in Cam4 toilet.
Huh.
I missed one.
I wonder what it could have been, though.
To Minto Phantom.
I wonder what it was.
Hmm.
Object replacement.
So that is a thing that happens.
What's the details?
Oh, look at that.
You get money based on everything you find.
This is in dollars, right?
Because if this is in yen, I'm getting paid pennies.
Yeah, we got paid 70 cents.
It's in yen.
Oh, gosh, I must be desperate.
All I could buy is a bubble gum or something.
Ouch.
Oh, some of them you get early bonuses too.
1.2.
Okay.
We're getting real strict about it.
Interesting.
D is nice.
Welcome to Mambuship.
Thank you.
You're an intern.
You get paid for exposure.
Yeah, I'm getting paid an exposure to the paranormal.
Exposure to creepy phenomena.
on but even if this were like if this were in dollars a
hundred and forty one dollars is kind of insane for this
kind of work that's kind of that's five hours of work for
141 dollars i'm almost due But don't say it like that.
It almost due for a bite kick in.
Good for a single day.
Maybe.
No hazard pay though.
I feel like you need the hazard pay, right, for this type of
job.
Let's select another property.
Am I just too good?
Let's see this one, the Totori residence.
Where a solitary death occurred.
It can't be that haunted then if only one person died there.
Just haunted?
What?
He's gonna do the same thing over and over and over again?
Cree!
Thank you so much for four bonds!
He's just- I'm just gonna see the same guy over and over and
over again.
Does this include insurance?
It's a great quest.
Decent pay aside from potential monsters.
What we could do is we could try and do the harder mode too,
maybe.
Yeah.
Start to work.
Mr. Mothor!
Thank you so much for the five.
Oh, boy, golly.
All right.
I'm enjoying this single postcard that is on the wall.
Let's skip this.
All right.
What's the unknown altar?
I wonder.
Oh.
This place is tight.
Holy cow.
Small, small.
Happy 21 Months Milestone.
The Thorias Bastard!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
I could be in that tub.
Ooh, I don't like this view at all.
Ooh, I don't like it at all.
What does that say?
Eye, heart?
Hawaii?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Searching around.
For some spooky things.
Did they have a chat?
Maybe it was like a grandma or grandpa that would have their
like grandchild come over and, you know.
Something like that.
This is like really, oh my gosh.
How much do I have?
Ooh, I don't like the bathtub.
Oh, oh, oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Scared me.
I need to be warm.
To all employees.
this is the time when there are many reports of abnormal
phenomena okay so they give you about 30 seconds to check
everything that's pretty nice it's dirty too yeah it's not
so good what was that how's the sound by the way i know that
it's like a pretty low game because it's just like ambiance
but if you need me to if you want me to turn it up let me
know It's good but good for...
It's quiet but good for loud sounds.
It's good.
Okay, cool.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, this was not read before.
Right?
Yeah, that's strange.
The toy.
Something up with the toy?
This one?
Was this here before?
This definitely has nothing happening, was it?
Yeah, it was there.
Okay.
What's it gonna say?
How do you even make anything?
Why do you have a table here in the middle of your kitchen?
Oh, oh, that's not good.
Oh, oh, oh, grandma.
I kind of wanted to see what would happen, though.
Maybe I should have let her come up.
She was just crawling up the stairs.
Grandma.
what it's hard sometimes because it like lights it up so
much that it seems like things are moving you know what i
mean what was that what broke she don't need your help up
the stairs oh my god oh my god that one actually got me
that one actually got me
Grandpa, please.
She was like, this is me not needing your stinking help
going up the stairs.
Youngster?
Oof.
That's not good.
That's some black mold.
Grandma had no midnight snacks.
This is like crazy.
So much stuff in this room.
Yeah, they were handprints.
Creepy.
Okay.
Now every time I click the night vision mode, I'm freaking
out.
I'm freaking out a little bit.
Blood on the door.
Here?
I don't think...
Grandma, what did I tell you about acting like a baby?
We're done with this role play.
I don't want to do it anymore.
Bobby.
Why did all people like regress back to babies?
Oh!
Do you think he's a danger?
No, I don't think he's so much worth the take.
It was Grandpa doing the baby roleplay.
Oh, my bad.
No, no.
We'll get rid of him.
Okay.
I know we would die if we don't report them but like some of
them I just want to see
some of them I want to see what happens I'm not ready for a
smooch That was a true Gachi Koi distance.
Grandma loves her being in front of the camera.
She is constantly...
Wait, what other ones then are there?
Oh.
Because it said multiple.
Birthday was on Monday.
Artemis, happy birthday!
Happy belated birthday!
We're missing a couple things, guys.
So we gotta lock in a bit.
Besides, like, the obvious stuff.
Wait, sorry.
Scanning?
The painting?
This one?
Multiple anomalies!
Oh!
Oh my god, that's freaky!
Wait, that was so good!
Oh.
There's more dust than normal.
That was so crazy.
Every time I turn it on, I think this is like a person
standing there, you know.
Orbs?
Yeah, dust.
You mean dust?
Suddenly a beard.
Who's going to be in this?
I almost said the toilet.
Who's going to be in that tub, I wonder?
It was white.
This one?
Oh, it was?
Oh my gosh.
You guys got it.
Oh wow.
I would have missed that.
Oh, nice catch.
Nice catch.
Oh, oh, oh.
Good catch, everybody.
I think every time you hear- You hear a noise?
I think it's like something's going on.
Wait, but somebody ran by!
Oh my god.
That's scary.
Maybe Grandpa Baby could fit in the tub.
I would need to get paid for babysitting if that were the
case.
Babysitter's charge a pretty penny that they do.
I was too slow.
I'm catching that guy.
What are your rates?
A bajillion dollars.
But yeah, I think every time you hear a sound, that's like
something's going on in another camera, you know?
Oh, I don't like that sound.
Okay.
Wait, what's...
Sorry.
Muay Thai gym.
Can't wait to be a deadly abu.
Thanks for the confidence to join.
Props to your apparition homie.
Kampa!
Good luck at the gym!
You got this.
The curtain opened.
This one?
No.
Oh my god!
Grandpa!
He's a farmer!
Cam 7 folder.
Cam 1 heater.
What are you talking about, heater?
I hardly even know where.
There is no- Oh, this thing?
Oh, it's on!
Oh my gosh!
We're gonna burn down the whole place!
I don't even notice.
It's just like normal.
This always looks like this from what I remember.
Like, I remember the guy, the picture, and then the document
kind of being blurred out.
I do remember that.
Grandma is cold.
Well, grandma can stay cold.
She's a ghost now.
That's kind of how we are.
So I can see that she's doing her morning exercise.
ghost activity.
Okay.
That's how I wake up too.
Gengi na ovae-chan da na.
She died
even though she's dead, she's still so even though she's
dead, she's still so full of energy.
No!
GENKY SOGIR!
Never, no, no.
She was just jamming in the bedroom.
Get done!
Tuna!
Kiboshi!
I think somebody's in the kitchen.
Oh,
you don't have to wash the dishes anymore.
I think the cabinet has always been open.
Because I've kind of been looking in there.
Maybe to see if there's like a face.
that will start peeking out from there or something.
I don't like this area because it's like so dark.
It's pretty scary.
4 a.m.
Oh my gosh, guys, we're killing it.
Sync color is not red.
Was it red before?
Wait, what?
I just heard someone running.
I just heard some running.
Oh,
was it?
I don't know.
Ah, nice.
Everything keeps turning right in this place.
Oh, maybe this cabinet is what someone was referring to
earlier.
I'm not sure if it was open or not before.
Nothing in here still?
Eee!
Who are you?
We've only had grandma and everyone before.
Wondering Taco!
Thank you so much for the hand-gifted!
Granddaughter, the whole family is here.
Oh,
I saw this reflection and thought it was something.
I don't think it is.
Does this look darker than before or am I crazy?
I think I'm crazy.
The red on the futons as well?
Oh, the painting!
It's actually changed.
sofa wasn't yellow oh wow it's like really bright yellow
the sofa has always been yellow apparently has it been that
bright oh there's some feet here
banana sofa some things you just like kind of accept and so
you don't really like think about it that it's that that
like oh you're like oh wait i i've seen this before but i
always just thought it was normal you know what i mean
now i'm questioning every color i see
i hear something something rattling
there's something about
what was it what did i hear rattling oh that's what i heard
rattling grandma how'd you get outside
oh yippee we missed one object growth shrink in cam one
living callahan welcome to bamboo ship thank you what a
funny one to end on
grandma nice
I wonder if when we get through all three of these, if this
will unlock, or if it's like a...
I forgot to say during the review stream, but I wanted to
mention the print I used as a mat on my Madi Incentro self.
Shelf was by Ayami Mama.
Oh, nice!
Deadboard!
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you!
Oh, gosh.
Now my nose is all clogged with ectoplasm.
Turns out grandma's not the ghost.
We just keep kicking her out of the house.
Yeah.
Ugh.
She's like, I ain't dead yet.
She's like, I still live here.
Let's
see the other one.
Grandma, your name is Arthur Lee's.
Hotel Selene, an abandoned lodging facility.
Yeah.
Ooh, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Alright, we have 30 seconds to observe this place.
What a creepy hallway.
What is it?
Why is it censored?
Oh!
Sexy bedrooms!
Wow.
Why are they censored?
Red!
Okay, so this room is red.
This room is gold.
It's yellow.
Red.
Oh, there's the pregnant lady.
I should be paying attention and not staring at her.
Oh, okay.
So there's eight cameras.
Ew, this place is disgusting.
I was trying to read what it said.
written on the on the wall but alas my nihongo isn't not to
joju enough i can't even see it barely i could barely see it
mothman oh sad sad face what is this though i need to know
my curiosity this is pee pee poo poo i don't think so i
think all right let's go guys we got this i wonder what kind
of ghosts are here Before we had grandma-grandpa...
Now we're gonna have...
Oh!
Lady.
Now we have Lady.
Um...
Okay.
That was really fast.
That was like really fast.
It says Red Village.
Was that always there?
Okay, it was.
I hear something.
I think something is like about.
Something is about.
At least this one is a pretty obvious hallway.
This one scares me though.
I don't like it.
This look like two little like ghost children sitting.
Okay.
There's an eye in that room.
In here?
Is this an eye?
I don't think so.
I think that was always there before.
Doesn't look like one.
Boy!
We have another lady.
Khorus, everybody likes this.
This room.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, the flowers are new.
This is so distracting because it looks like movement, you
know?
She having a bit of a chuckle.
Oh, oh, ah, ah, ah, eh, eh.
Oh, what's so funny?
What's so funny?
I keep saying this and it looks like lumps of like a body,
you know?
Ah, freaky.
Freaky, freaky.
Their sisters?
Oh.
Oh, what's going on in here?
Oh my god!
Bugs!
Moths!
Where'd they go?
A total moth attack!
I'm gonna see if this is anything.
No.
Something's going on.
The bugs are back.
The bugs are back in town.
Bugs are back in town.
The bugs are back in town Bugs are back in town
Oh baby Baby shadow
Get out of here on my Torah Yeah so true
Hmm Karaoke is next stream Sorry I'll never sing ever again
in a stream that is not karaoke.
I don't like how
these rooms look so similar.
You guys hear that?
That one I don't like.
I don't... Oh gosh, I keep thinking this is a Silent Hill
monster.
What is that?
Oh, she's singing.
Oh, I'm getting closer to it.
Oh my god, she's brushing her hair!
You look, you look beautiful.
That's mom.
That's mommy.
Ooh.
Someone's knocking.
Wait, was this already there?
No.
Or yes, it was.
I guess.
It's so bright.
Knock, knock, hello.
Who is it?
This place looks chill.
You think so?
Even though we got attacked by moths, literally in this
room.
Uh-oh.
Alright, guys, we gotta lock in.
There's, like, so many things.
Everything is, like, so dirty.
It's hard to see it, like, if there'd be a...
Oh!
Sometimes the anomaly is just...
Literally just staring you in the face.
Oh.
Ooh, that one's freaking.
Some anomalies are easier than others.
Yeah, exactly.
so funny.
That one was so silly.
I wonder what we'll get in here.
This room's creepy.
I'm like waiting to see someone standing in one of these
windows.
I am too scared of baby.
Are you saying you're too baby?
Are you saying You were too, baby.
There's a kid, little baby.
It's okay.
Anomalies get a bit quirky.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Multiple anomalies are detected.
You guys hear that?
Like, there's someone stepping on glass.
Oh!
The lady's gone.
The sensor is gone!
Oh!
Crunchy.
Hold on, it's gotta be one of the rooms, right?
Oh, the whole...
They took the bed!
No more pregnant.
They took the whole bed!
That's a crime!
That's not even an anomaly.
They're just straight up stealing.
Alright, now.
Invisible bed.
bed freaky ghost bed yeah yeah yeah yeah nothing outside yet
there has to be something out here that i'm missing right oh
my god the baby is a danger there's an extra floor what do
you mean there's an extra floor oh like this that was that
was That wasn't always there?
Oh, you're so right.
There must be something I'm missing that's so obvious.
It just looked kind of like it belonged there.
The baby was too cute to be scary.
I know he looks so happy.
He's just a happy baby.
I don't like this area.
It's so dark.
Something scary.
Oh, that means something outside is happening.
Oh, yeah.
What is happening?
Red paint on cam 7.
Oh, it's always been red.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's always been red.
Wee-woo.
He looked like that one Pokemon.
Like saw.
Sock on.
That's what he looked like.
Oh.
Ew, he's burnt.
Forest in the shower.
Oh!
This?
Oh my gosh.
Fire in the water.
It just looked like a window to me.
Wow, that was a good catch.
That was a really good catch.
Good catch.
That's so funny.
Was that a dead woman?
Well, it's a...
I was...
There's a lot of dead people.
Are you talking about me?
I'm the dead woman.
These rooms are tricky for me.
Oh my god!
That is a lady in the bathroom.
And I don't like that.
The boiler was opening.
Oh it was?
Oh!
There's a hand!
Oh my gosh, you guys are so right.
Creepy.
Hand in the boiler.
Lady in the shower.
Water in the fire.
Get back in there.
Back.
Back, ghost.
Get back.
Get back in the shower, you smell.
Oh my gosh, we're already at four.
Oh, she's looking at me.
I didn't do that.
I don't take responsibility.
The blue graffiti outside looks off.
I can try it.
I don't think so, though.
No.
This is exactly how I react to my crush.
You tell her she's stinky?
Isn't that...
Oh, wait, this is also...
Right?
It's not supposed to be open here.
Yeah.
Isn't it like being mean to your...
To your...
Like to someone you're into.
Isn't that supposed to be a dating tactic?
But...
Or like some sort of tactic.
Eee!
Uh oh.
Somebody's inside.
Oh!
She's inside.
Oh.
You are haunting the wrong place.
Go back to the first location.
Oh my gosh.
What if the, like the, what's it called?
It's close by.
The rest stop that she was haunting before.
All these ghosts think something's really funny.
And I think I'm not in on the joke.
And I'm really upset about it.
I would like to know.
I'm getting FOMO.
because I will understand.
No, dummy.
Why are you called dummy for?
Maybe she's haunting me?
Maybe we did kind of get ourselves a girl.
Maybe being mean to them does work.
Ghost bottom right.
Affirmative.
Face in the wall?
KM2 face?
Oh.
Oh my god I thought you meant like On the wall wall Oh my
god Anti-ghost Anti-ghost club No please I thought I was
looking at the walls walls Not like Because you know
sometimes like a face will appear like Kind of like as a
reflection Looking thing I wasn't expecting someone's head
popping out She was just peeking.
What a voyeur.
Pervert.
You pervert.
Oh.
Oh, we made it.
I missed two.
Intruder.
And Ghost Camp 2 Isle.
I thought, what?
Maybe it had just appeared.
I did hear, like, a knocking.
As soon as I, as soon as the day.
They stopped so.
147 yen, guys.
We can go buy Onigiri.
We can go buy a Onigiri.
Or something.
Cool.
Wait, let's see now.
An undiscovered property has been released.
If you are ready, please start watching.
Not the animal clinic.
Sight of a palace.
fatal incident traces still remain inside no filling onigiri
corn potage I have some corn potage oh this one was that
supposed to mean I'm scared I did see that Vicky played this
and it made me want to play it I didn't watch her her
playthrough though because I was like hold it I did see like
that this game was going around so I was interested in it
but then I saw she played it and I was like okay I want to
play it too all right shall we go to the animal clinic I
hope there's cats okay skip a skip a all right let's see
what we got we have seven cage we have seven uh seven
locations why that dog giving me the side eye like that
Onigitia is my salary.
I'm getting paid in food?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this arm, you guys, is not an anomaly.
It's always there.
Dang, this place is really...
I think this place...
Oh, okay.
And the mannequin.
This place needed to go under a while ago because, um...
What the heck is this?
Why is there a cage like that?
Okay, so there's only...
seven cameras this time cool cool why how where do you even
examine the animals
like where where do you examine them the glove is killing me
what if it really it might be i don't think so every cam is
cluttered as hecky i know it's really difficult this is like
worse I wonder if grandma will be here too.
This doesn't look like a vet.
Why do we have like a...
This looks like when you get radiation or whatever.
Alright guys.
The time where abnormal phenomena occur.
Oh shoot the shoes.
Okay that was fast.
That was really fast.
X-ray apron.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Was this cat always yelling?
Was that cat always mean?
No, okay, it was.
Someone's running around.
I'm scared.
Wait, it's so...
It's so cluttered.
Something's in the cages.
Ow!
Oh, naked, naked old man.
Oh, thank you for showing me your mouth and nothing else.
so what um what happened to you i keep seeing this and
thinking it's like somebody all right i gotta i gotta stop
zooming by so quickly because some of these are gonna be
kind of subtle you know so
we gotta we gotta look a little closer we gotta use our eyes
not keep our eyes shut for more than three seconds
Don't get me with the arm on the table.
Caged Walter White.
You know what?
Keep him caged.
Was this open before?
Or was it...
Oh, sorry.
Was it shut?
It was open.
Okay.
I'm glad you guys have better memories than I do.
Uh-huh.
I can't stop looking at this dog.
Oh, there's blood here.
And also someone knocking.
So someone's inside again.
Hello?
Somebody knocking at a door.
What the heck?
Who could that be?
Hold on.
Oh, I'm searching for... Oh, oh, oh!
With the man face!
That's like a popular yokai.
What's it?
Oh gosh, what's her name again?
The dog.
Yeah, it's a yokai.
He got that dog in him.
He embraced...
That's what happens when you really embrace the dog in you.
You become the dog.
Oh!
They handle exotic animals too, it seems.
Why is there an elephant?
Address him!
The elephant is in the room.
Address me.
What if everybody What if everybody thinks he's saying
Address me?
But he's really Saying Undress Me
Side eye dog Stay in the same
I'm looking Where Where are you?
Redmond's scary Oh wait I should be clicking on this,
shouldn't I?
Oh I guess it covers the whole room so it's fine Okay good
Cool, cool, cool.
Look at these cats.
I can't stop looking at them, too.
They're so cute, cuddled in.
Oh, I miss my cats.
They're just in the other room.
Oh, calendar was always like that, right?
I think so.
It was always kind of folded.
Did you play Zucosis?
No.
I didn't play it because I don't like, like, animal horror
so oh hey I was trying to report you come on lady side-eyed
dog is my spirit edible cam six there's a neck I think this
was always though how the the mannequin has been at the
Royal Ontario Museum today saw some folks doing Oshikatsu
with Fumoko dolls.
I asked them if they needed help taking photos because I was
doing the same thing with my beat doll.
They recognized you immediately.
Oh my gosh!
Skeletons!
That was so fun.
Oh.
Wait, does this not pause the game?
Oh, shoot.
I thought it was.
Happy Friday, Vity Fresh.
Happy Friday!
That's so cute, doll.
Bonding through Oshikatsu.
Thank you for the super chest.
you guys thank you thank you huh i guess not i guess it
doesn't pause the game that's so scary i'm just trying to
read my chart please ghosts from one ghost to another can
you leave me alone
had a kidney stone for a week on top of having to move to a
new apartment watching your crow country let's play helped
keep me sane oh my gosh i hope you're feeling better That
sounds so horrible.
I keep saying this guy here too.
I don't know if it's like the yokai band face dog guy.
The arm?
You got...
Wait, is it an actual arm now?
Oh, it is.
It became... it went from mannequin to real arm.
That's silly.
That's really silly.
I hope you're okay.
I hope you're feeling better.
I'm glad that my gaming could help you out a little bit.
Hmm.
We haven't had anything in this room.
Oh my gosh.
Multiple anomalies.
Where?
I'm not really locked in for this one.
Sorry.
Were the handcuffs?
I did see those on the ground.
These things, right?
I don't think they were here before.
What are they?
What is that?
Okay, I'm glad that you also saw it because I was hovering
over it.
I was hovering over it.
Like, I should maybe get it or something, you know?
They were just handcuffs.
Why do you have to go off immediately when I press the
button?
This one is a little less active, it feels.
An invisible man.
I don't think the chain thing in the cage was always there
either.
Also, I'm going to click on the neck so that you guys if...
Maybe... Yeah, see?
It's not an anomaly.
This thing?
Uh, this is just a water catcher, so I don't see why it
would be an anomaly.
This is like when the, when the, when it rains and stuff.
It's just to catch the water.
Unless he meant a different chain.
Um,
has to, whoa!
I was about to say there has to be something in here!
Oh my god, that was crazy.
Kind of looks like a sneak.
But it's right in front of us.
In here?
Here?
Where is it?
Where did that sound come from?
Ah!
Sorry.
Was that a face under the table?
On the left.
I don't see anything.
Oh my gosh.
More multiple anomalies!
Please!
I feel like I'm gonna die on this one.
Ah!
Please!
Come out, come out wherever you are!
Huh?
Oh!
I see him.
Manikin has a real hand.
Not anymore!
To our employees, hey don't skip me, what are you?
everything's so cluttered i can't tell we haven't had
anything in this room either or maybe we have oh oh that's
that's the worst i don't like that one at all
that one was terrible standing here i realized multiple
again oh my god Gosh, guys.
The folds in the cat calendar?
Are they really?
I noticed that too.
Okay, yeah.
It's not an anomaly, though.
Do you ever think about how they get rid of anomalies in
these games?
I do think about that.
Like, what do they?
What is the procedure?
Oh, my God.
We didn't make it, right?
We still get paid.
holy you missed four object replacement object replacement
door closing in the operating room object replacement or
opening closing but yeah of course object replacement in the
operating room I'm not gonna see that at all should we try
again that one oh we made it to 405 No!
Let's try again.
Object replacement.
And then it also said in here in the cage.
Accident scene.
I just noticed that.
Scary.
Okay, excuse me.
Go away.
Behind operating room.
Reception.
This is a reception.
How are we supposed to get anything done?
Door opening, closing in the operating room.
Is there a door in here?
Huh.
Look out for the Cam 1 top right mad dog.
Uh, this guy?
Oh, this guy?
Oh, he was mad!
It's a lion!
Oh, I saw it angry and didn't realize it wasn't supposed to
be angry, though.
Ah, okay, okay.
I did see what it looked like, though.
I did see it was like, it had its like, it was like, like,
like that.
but I didn't see okay opening closing in here and then
object replacement okay we got like a tissue box here we got
a red box here we got the arm it's also said it didn't say
examination table I don't think
thank you for the roars you guys want to hear my Godzilla
roar I don't know I could be, I, okay.
I've done better.
Somebody's here.
Show it yourself.
Or don't.
That's okay with me too.
Show it.
Oh!
Hand.
I've done better.
I have to listen to it.
And then I would really be able to get it.
I promise.
Godzilla.
Why were there handcuffs?
I guess...
Maybe because it was the accident scene is what it's called.
Maybe that's why the...
The...
What's it called?
The handcuffs were there in that.
room i'm always looking at this arm now i'm looking at these
papers up here
was this door always open double checking i kind of want to
have a gladjita as a pet oh this door shut oh my gosh freaky
oh my gosh though i really like the audio cues actually like
the audio hints are really you could be on like a totally
different camera like a totally different scene and you only
hear it it's like really freaky and they're helpful yeah
freaky and helpful okay so this guy i think is real
someone knocking again someone knocking again wait hold on
go back here i'm checking that Oh!
Yee!
We're getting new ones this time!
We're getting new ones this time, that's cool!
I'm always a fan of seeing more different kinds of content.
You know?
Lady in red.
I hear something.
Very faint.
Oh.
Why is the cat angry?
Is there a wire in cam 2?
Hold on, we'll get there.
A wire in cam 2.
Oh, the hand!
Because cat...
Skulls in cam 2?
There's always been skulls here, no?
I'll report them.
Yeah, they've always been there.
A wire.
thing because it's not always been here too
oh someone's around what what what can i help you can i help
you can i no no hot dog can i help oh it's like it's i guess
it's the person's name and it's saying like Don't forget
her.
Oh.
I guess maybe the person that died here?
Boo.
That was freaky.
Hope you're having fun with the spooks.
It's spooky for sure.
Thanks for the hot dog.
Hot dog.
That one was Pretty spooky.
Forget who, I guess the lady that died here, I'm assuming.
It's a lady's dog with the side eye.
So funny.
It's just not angry.
Little lion isn't angry.
Right.
Oh!
What was that sound?
What was that?
This thing?
I was talking about having Godzilla as a pet and I can't
help but remember the 90s Godzilla...
Oh, there he is.
The 90s Godzilla animated series, which basically had that
concept, which is awesome, by the way.
Godzilla as a pet.
I think I would take on a kaiju as a pet.
Linear Lion Nobel.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh.
I just heard the cage.
A cage.
I heard cage.
I heard cage sound, no?
I heard.
But his breath is so stinky and nuclear.
I think, like, one of my more fascinations, like, one of my
fascinations of Godzilla are, like, his evolutions.
Like, the Shin Godzilla evolutions.
And when he's, like, mid-evolution.
and his eyes are, whoop, are like bulging out of his head,
you know?
So crazy.
And like, his, his,
hold on.
I'm like locked in.
Oh!
His old man again!
Please don't!
Ah!
How is like, he's trying to do his nuclear breath.
Nuclear- nuclear beam What if instead Wait, this was not
here Is that like a copy of something?
Oh no, maybe it was Just kidding I thought it was like a
Freaky like you know Someone hacked my printer And started
printing out PPs Something Nuclear breath What if I didn't
have Minto Minto beam What if I had Nuclear Minto Beam.
Nuclear Minto Breath.
Well, so far we haven't been warned yet.
Honestly, I feel like this...
Oh, he's angry!
He's angry!
I feel like this round has been kind of dead.
I say, and then some guy is just gonna, like, pop up in my
face right now.
Right now.
Okay, good.
I'm glad it didn't happen, actually.
Would it be flavored?
Would it need a flavor?
It could be minty.
It could be like a mouthwash.
Sometimes that stuff feels like a nuclear blast to your
mouth.
You know what I mean?
Because it's like so...
You're like...
You're like, this is just painful.
Oh!
The dog is crying!
Oh, it also says it here!
I can't read my Nihonko is not It's like I can like Ya
Kawako Wasuru na don't forget about her I can't I can't read
it though My Nihonko not Joju enough Kanji!
Someone else translate it Or
It's very difficult, right?
I can't read it.
It's a very difficult language.
I don't know how to read the word.
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot!
Wait, no, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please.
Oh!
Can I get a nuclear Minto beam?
Nuclear Minto.
I'm not forgetting about you, lady.
Don't you.
Forget about her.
I can't believe the dog actually changed.
That's so funny.
Cat carrier door opened Cam 5.
This thing?
Is it not supposed to be open?
Nope.
It's supposed to be open.
Hmm.
Oh, it's scary.
Oh, it's only there if it's not night vision.
Is your memory gone?
Are you feeling numb?
Can I...
Oh, that's an alligator!
That's a straight up alligator.
Not even a crocodile.
Last time we had an elephant.
Now we have an alligator.
Hey there, alligator.
Oh,
I just heard running.
Oh my gosh.
Who?
Who is in here?
Who is running around?
No running in this establishment.
No handcuffs this time.
Oh, there he is.
This guy again.
Oh, there's so many jars.
Oh, I know.
I'll be honest I have not looked in this area maybe even
once I've looked everywhere but there so I just looked at it
and I was like I just realized I don't know what anything
looks like in that area
Handcuffs?
Wait, are the handcuffs back?
The handcuffs are not supposed to be there.
Yeah, we haven't gotten the warning yet.
We're killing it, guys.
We're killing it?
Yeah, no handcuffs.
No handcuffs.
Oh,
we only have 30 seconds left, though.
I think we got this, guys.
Sad-eyed dog.
I think we have it.
Ah!
Zo!
Tattoos on the mannequin neck.
I think that's not tattoos.
I think it's like like the paint is chipping away.
They've always been there though.
Yo, yo, yo.
Oh.
I think we've got this.
We have 10 seconds?
Anyone want to make a surprise visit in the last 10 seconds?
Nobody.
Wait, I think I just heard something.
Anybody want to make an appearance?
Nobody.
Lights in the camp 3.
Oh my god.
Oh come on, no!
We don't have time for you!
Successfully completed normal operations for all properties.
No!
I had you!
Dang.
The operating room lamp changed.
Oh, did it?
Oh, is that what the...
the one in the...
Dang it!
Oh well, that's okay.
Oh, congratulations, you have now completed your regular
monitoring duties for all of the affected properties.
Check to see if there are any more anomalous phenomena that
have not yet been reported.
Forgot to mention with everything going on, it was my
birthday a couple days ago!
Would you feel up to giving yourself a sincere compliment?
Wait, giving me a compliment for your birthday.
Jolly ram rancher.
Happy birthday!
Ah.
Uh, compliment to me?
Uh.
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh.
I could find anomalies well yeah I could see things mostly
good
yeah maybe I see dead people and so do you apparently oh my
gosh wait anomalies reported 22 out of 61 in just the first
area no way 22 out of 45 freaking man baby
there's so many 21 out of 55.
should we do round two for everything
Thanks, Raider, baby.
What's the special pay mode?
There's even more anomalies!
Look, 81!
No, stinking way.
We can try it.
Wait, what did it say special pay mode was?
Oh, oh, oh, good.
One is a million.
An 81.
Let's try it.
I believe we can do it.
Alright.
It's been a while since we've seen this place, so let's go
back over it again.
I have the bus coming.
I wish you one day she'll see why.
What?
Thank you, Jolly, Ravanger.
I think Grandpa Baby wants a baby bottle of beer.
Why is it right?
But it's creepy.
Okay, so we have 30 seconds, I think?
We only have three false reports this time.
Three false reports this time.
Instead of five.
And apparently 81 anomalies that are possible, which is
crazy.
Kenei!
Welcome back, thank you.
Oh,
no, never mind.
It's already started.
Okay.
We do not get a warning at all.
Or we don't get 30 seconds.
They're like, you're in the game now.
Okay, this is it.
Oh, oh, all the chairs left and became a big old block.
Someone really... That seems like efficient cleaning up,
actually.
Okay.
Things are happening now, guys.
Oh my gosh, scary.
Okay.
Keep your eyes.
eyes peeled.
I thought we would have the 30 seconds to look, but they're
like, no, this is expert mode.
You don't need 30 seconds.
The chair cube!
Uh-oh, someone then?
Woo!
What the heck is?
Ew.
Ew!
That has nice teeth, though.
we should oh we've gotten this one before i was literally
just about to say we shouldn't get repeats so much because
there's 81 but maybe there's just that many more anomalies
that occur in that you know was that sound
was this always so long
The pot in the bathroom camera.
What about it?
We'll head back there.
Nope, that's always been like that.
Oh!
Blood splatter.
Oh, and there's a face up here!
Oh my gosh, now each scene has multiple anomalies too.
Okay, oh my goodness.
The sign in camp 3.
Let's see.
What did you guys see?
Hold on.
Let me go, thank you!
This sign?
Is there something weird with it?
No?
No.
Don't think so.
Ah, big toilet.
Big toilet.
Wow, they're like going crazy active right now.
There's like everything.
happening.
Okay, we haven't looked in this area in a bit.
It's fall?
Man, toilet.
I heard the footsteps, though.
Someone is walking around.
Someone is around.
I'm surprised we have not gotten anything in here.
Like, that's actually so surprising.
Oh my god!
Season-changing ghost?
Actually?
Are we gonna see this break?
My force!
Yeah!
Oh!
Ha!
Okay, I give up.
Um...
Hmm.
Oh!
Why do you look so worried?
I'm the one worried.
It's like when you look at a spider, the spider is scared of
you, but you're scared of the spider.
Like, you shouldn't be the one concerned.
I'm the one concerned.
I'm the one scared of you.
Minto Skywalker.
Yes.
The force is in me.
with me.
May the force be with you and it's with me.
Oh, I thought this was swinging.
Uh oh.
We got knocking.
Who's knocking?
Where could you be?
Where are you at?
Oh my god, the graffiti!
Sick, sick, sick, sick.
Someone was it knocking?
Yeah, they put too many sixes.
Come on, guys, come on.
It's extra evil.
Yeah, they really wanted to make sure that it was like...
You know.
They were like, if 666...
Oh, there's a face on the roof.
If 666 is evil, then it'll be extra evil if we add another
one.
Was there a hole with the tables on cam 2?
I think that's okay.
I think that one's okay.
Ha!
I give up.
Sure doesn't feel like we're getting 80 anomalies happening
now, does it?
Guy at the top of cam 5.
Guy?
I don't think that's a guy.
I think that's just the hole.
But I didn't notice this ladder that's freaky oh what a
thrill the lights on what a thrill like actually it's really
a thrill because it's so spooky so scary what am i doing
what do you mean what am i doing i'm doing my job and i'm
getting paid pennies for it yenis even i'm getting paid
yenis for it after this shift i'm to go buy myself a nice
onigiri no no filling
y 'all y'all y'all y'all y'all which one am i saying guys
lorrell lorrell which did you oh which did you hear
Wario.
Which did you hear?
Okay, I'll try it again.
Alright, tell me if you hear Yanny or Laurel.
Yanny.
The roof is gone.
Oh my gosh, right good catch good catch good catch
third time's a charm ha oh the dog side eye but it's not as
cute when a human does it wait is it cute if I do it to you
the side eye Yeah?
Really?
I know the time is going the same speed.
Oh, someone is walking on glass.
I know it's the same speed, but it just feels longer.
I don't know what it is.
Where are you?
around.
I heard them.
I don't think I've ever seen you doing something that's not
cute.
How about when I'm being really spooky scary?
That shouldn't be cute.
That should be spooky scary, obviously.
Okay, well, we haven't gotten yelled at.
Hmm.
I'm still...
Oh no, we're getting yelled at!
Oh, that's a slug.
That's just a straight-up slug.
I think we found the intruder.
Cam 7 is trash.
The trash is...
is an anomaly!
The litter is an anomaly.
Oh my gosh, the litter is an anomaly.
Okay, I saw it and I thought so, but I was like, maybe I
just am misremembering.
What the heck?
What the heck, a dial?
We are smart.
Yeah, good catch.
Good catch.
Oh, spooky.
I don't like the two-parter.
But they said Cam 7.
Was that not the one that I did?
This is a Cam 7.
You're reading Isle 2.
It's not Cam 2.
It's Cam 7.
Are the windows in Cam 6 always purple?
I don't like that.
Uh, I don't know.
We gotta go find that noise.
We're gonna get jump scared.
Oh!
Hello.
I wonder what's paranormal.
Oh, we found this the creepy.
Were you the one making that noise?
Okay, well, it stopped.
Was this always here?
This graffiti?
I'm going to report it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I learned my lesson.
Oh, someone was eating here.
Someone was cooking here.
Someone cooked here.
Why are we having a dinner at my...
at this place, huh?
Someone cooked here.
What the heck?
Okay, I'll grab it before it disappears, but it was funny to
just watch it move.
I'm angry why doesn't it work why doesn't it work one of
these days it'll work
all these places look like a perfect place for one of
walter's labs oh that's that's just an eyeball there's not
even a face in the darkness it's just an eyeball um i think
these places are too dark you know too contaminated maybe
hmm a
nuclear breath oh
my gosh we just have 30 seconds left that was I boo yes and
speaking is this a face it was Speaking of, don't forget to
get your eyes checked.
Okay, we have multiple anomalies, though.
Like this, breaking!
Cha!
Oh!
There's a...
Oh my gosh, severed head.
I get it, I get it.
Multiple anomaly.
We just...
Something just broke.
The toilet!
Wait, there's another head up here!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god!
That one was really tough to see.
It was like right below you guys.
Eee!
No!
Why wouldn't it- Okay.
I think we might be able to do this, guys.
We did see a lot more of the anomalies.
The fine China!
That's freaky.
That one's cool.
Alright, we have one... Oh!
No!
What do you mean I missed one anomaly?
I just got there.
This job really makes you lose your head.
This job makes me lose my mind.
Up in here?
Up in here.
We got 200 yen now.
Nishakuen!
Get the whole!
Yay!
Goodbye, our onigiri.
Dang it.
I feel like, though, I didn't miss that one.
I just didn't have time to report it.
We were right there.
i was actually going to the toilet though we can eat yeah
this one will have filling what do you guys have if you've
had a onigiri before what do you like in it are you i might
like i really like a tuna mayo tuna tuna mayonnaise there's
one at the natural lawson that i get very often which is my
favorite um if you've ever Sometimes regular Lawson's have
them too.
But it's a...
Hold on.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh, I need it.
Oh, sorry.
For Windows Sam.
I need it.
Oh, I found it.
I found it immediately.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm trying to see if I can get like the packaging
though.
So if you guys ever see it.
Here, here, here.
This is my favorite.
This one.
It doesn't have like a fish in it.
But what it does have.
This.
It has like the edamame and stuff.
And some seaweed.
And it doesn't use like white rice.
So it's like a little healthier.
Oh my god this one though.
It's so.
It's so good.
there's no like filling inside like you know like a normal
one but this it's like it's so so yummy
it's not too dry no i'm never not that i think at least at
this one though it's so yummy oh yeah it says right there
rice with barley and amame and salted kelp yeah this is my
It's super duper yummy.
It's so yummy.
So every time I go to Lawson, I get that one.
And if they don't have it, I go to another Lawson.
Yummy.
But yeah, I do like a Tuna Mayo.
And sometimes they make ones that are...
It depends on the convenience.
But sometimes they make ones that are...
That are like...
How do you say?
Oh,
like an omu rice.
Yeah, they're like an omu rice, so they'll be wrapped in
egg, and then the filling on the inside is ketchup.
Friend of mine made a salmon and chili jam onigiri.
I think about it every day.
Wait, that sounds so good.
Wait, but would I be able to have it?
It's kind of sound spicy.
Yeah, it is.
It's yummy, yummy.
I was excited to see a Lawson's in Hawaii, but there was
nothing Lawson's about it.
Why?
Is it similar to like how the American 7-Eleven has like,
has very different menu as well, maybe?
I think some of the food I eat may actually kill you.
well a good thing i'm actually dead it might send me though
somewhere not somewhere beyond i what's beyond the afterlife
i wonder it might make me reincarnate it might like shoot me
into a new life what if it like forces me to reincarnate as
like an aunt don't do that to me the bathroom the back rooms
or the bathrooms
to me 7-11 we have in Hawaii is pretty solid especially for
US store oh I do know that like that you know obviously
there's a lot of like Japanese tourists that go to Hawaii
because it's like it's like even more exotic Okinawa they're
like yeah I've been to the United States oh yeah on the
mainland no I went to Hawaii
but I mean I don't blame them either I still want to try
going to Okinawa though I want to go I want to go should we
should we do what wait how many did we get here then 45 out
of 80 we did get like a good handful handful more anomalies
with this one I kind of want to try the the residents Maybe.
It's only 55.
I feel like we could maybe get all of them.
Maybe.
What?
It takes about like 20 minutes to play, you know?
So then I could have an hour to rest.
Oh!
Maybe I should.
Spam Musubi.
Oh yeah.
I'm hoping to go to Japan for a honeymoon eventually.
That sounds so nice!
sounds so nice well i think i think we i think we got to see
a lot of stuff i'm really glad we did this one on the on the
special pay because we saw so many more so many more
anomalies so i think we did i think we did well good job
team good job well i'm gonna raid you into my next stream
which is uh in about an hour and 15 minutes i'm gonna be
doing karaoke so i would love to see you there as thank you
guys for hanging out with me for this little spooky game
spooky time a little bit of a shorter stream but that's a
okay thank you guys thank you thank you i will see you when
i see you next hopefully in about an hour thank you thank
you bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you thank you thank you
see you see you you